c'est la compagnie Ruby River capital un
promoteur et investisseur de GNL Québec
qui a déposé une demande au centre
international pour les règlements des
différents relatifs aux investissements
du Groupe de la Banque mondiale il
s'agit d'un tribunal qui vise à régler
des mises quand à des investissements
internationaux on ignore pourquoi ce
montant ainsi que les raisons mais des
arguments en lien avec l'ALENA et la
Séoul serait évoqué GNL Québec n'a pas
voulu commenter la faire mais elle
rendra ses documents publics d'ici un
mois ou deux selon le professeur en
droit Charles Emmanuel côté une demande
d'indemnisation aussi élevée alors que
le projet n'a jamais vu le jour est
exagéré ça m'apparaît là première vue un
peu un peu exagéré écoutez des demandes
de 20 milliards de dollars et là il y a
il y en a eu à peu près jamais dans ce
type de d'arbitrage là il est plus
grands montants qui ont été réclamés
contre le Canada par le passé puis il
n'a jamais eu à payer de tels montants
là c'était des demandes de 500 500
millions de dollars dans la région du
Saguenay Lac Saint-Jean la demande
d'arbitrage fait sourciller certains
élus dont le député bloquiste de
Jonquières mari croient qu'une telle
réclamation envoie un mauvais message à
la population je me demande qu'est-ce
que ça prend à GNL pour comprendre que
ce projet-là ne se fera pas au Québec
j'ai l'impression que l'entreprise
cherche peut-être à avoir un entendre
hors pour égomies les dépenses qui ont
été associées à son projet de son côté
le député conservateur de Chicoutimi le
Fiore Richard Martel qui avait
ouvertement défendu le projet a préféré
ne pas commenter c'est le tribunal de la
Banque mondiale qui devra trancher si
les deux parties ne s'entendent pas un
règlement qui pourrait prendre quelques
années ce même tribunal est toutefois
controversé puisqu'il a le pouvoir de
forcer des États à indemniser des
entreprises privées ce tribunal qui est
tenu par la Banque mondiale et l'objet
d'ailleurs de vie de critique puisqu'il
consiste grosso modo à attenter au
levier politique et réglementaire que
dispose un état pour décider des
activités économiques qui se déroulent
sur son territoire si certains croyaient
que le projet de GNL Québec était mort
et enterré les promoteurs eux dans
cependant pas dit leur dernier mot ici
Julien boudrogothier Radio-Canada
Saguenay